[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello everyone,
and please join me
in welcoming Asif Saleh.
Asif is a Senior Director
of Strategy, Communications,
and Empowerment for BRAC
and BRAC International.
He oversees the advocacy
information and communication
technology and
communications departments,
as well as social
innovation lab.
He also manages BRAC's
empowerment initiatives,
including human rights and legal
aid services, migration, urban,
and skills development programs.
Prior to joining
BRAC in 2011, he
was the Executive
Director at Goldman Sachs
and previously worked for IBM.
He was recognized for his
work by Asia Society's Asia 21
program, the Bangladeshi
American Foundation,
and was selected as
an Asia 21 fellow.
Asif connects private
and social sectors
to develop and scale
innovations that uplift some
of the world's poorest people.
A bit of context on BRAC.
BRAC is the world's largest
nonprofit organization
and is based in Bangladesh.
It's a global leader in
developing and implementing
cost effective,
evidence based programs,
to assist more
marginalized people
in extremely poor, conflict
prone, and post disaster
settings.
These include initiatives
in education, health care,
micro-finance, girls
empowerment, agriculture,
human and legal
rights, and more.
In 2016, BRAC employed more than
110,000 people in 11 countries,
with a global expenditure
of about 900 million.
With low middle income countries
like Bangladesh developed
developing very rapidly, both
high and low tech solutions
will be instrumental
in bridging growth
growing socioeconomic divide.
Asif provides
insight on how BRAC
will reach 130 million people
in changing the way poverty is
addressed worldwide.
Thank you, please
take the floor.
ASIF SALEH: Thank you so much.
Let me start talking a
little bit about myself, just
to give a personal context.
I grew up in Bangladesh,
and when I was 18
I left to get my higher
education in the United States.
So I got a degree
in Computer Science,
and when I graduated, what
I wanted to do with my life
was more about solving
business problems.
And I graduated at the time when
tech jobs were quite plentiful,
and I landed with four
offers before I finished
my graduation, and I decided to
take up a job at Goldman Sachs.
And my motivation
was that I didn't
want to be a
programmer who was just
coding at the back bench,
just nobody looks at him,
I actually wanted to be
where I work with people
and solve problems.
And before I knew it, I spent
almost 12 years at Goldman,
working with trading, and
electronic trading, algorithms,
and all these things.
But something was
not quite right.
And I felt like this was not
quite what I was meant to do.
Probably not the
kind of problems
I wanted to solve for
the rest of my life.
So I started a
charity back in 2001
in my free time, which was
a platform for diaspora
Bangladeshis to
connect and also work
on a cause for human rights
victims in Bangladesh.
And the idea was
to raise awareness
on human rights issues and
also to rehabilitate them.
And I'm glad to see there
is a fellow member here,
[INAUDIBLE], who's here,
who was a member of this
and I connected with a
lot of young Bangladeshis
during that time.
And the organization
actually grew quite rapidly.
Before I knew it, we had like
nine chapters in nine cities,
and we were connected
all around the world.
And we were doing
projects and we had
5,000 people in our network.
So that was my thing.
I figured that this is something
that I was kind of prone to do,
so I had to take
a leap of faith.
I had to decide what I wanted
to do with the rest of my life.
So at one point, I decided
to end my career at Goldman,
and move back to
Bangladesh, and started
to work in the
development sector.
And that's where the
rest of my life started.
So I actually, from the
number one investment bank,
I joined the number one NGO,
which is the BRAC, so quite
a large shift.
But interestingly, from what
to add to what [INAUDIBLE] said
about BRAC, I think
when I joined BRAC,
it was quite an
interesting learning,
because BRAC is
something so unique
that there isn't
a lot of charity
organizations like BRAC.
Because BRAC kind
of uses whatever
works to solve a
developing problem.
So whether it's business, if
it's a market based solutions,
I think it's fairly agnostic
to what kind of solution
would work.
And that resulted to BRAC
from being a very small relief
organizations to what a giant
behemoth that it is right now,
which has very, very large
scale programs in education,
to running the largest
non-government school network,
to one of the largest
microfinance network,
to very big health networks
all around the country.
And it expanded
outside Bangladesh
about 12 years ago now,
it's in 12 other countries.
So as you heard, it's total
budget, global budget,
is about $1.1 billion,
with about 70%
of Bangladesh's budget comes
from its own resources.
And we are slowly on a path
to become self-dependent
for our Bangladesh programs in
the next five to seven years.
But what BRAC has is that
it's quite unique in the sense
that it has these large scale
programs that I mentioned.
It also has about 15
social enterprises.
It has about seven
large investments
that it made, from bank,
to insurance companies,
to various other at a
university, it's quite unique.
But there is a kind of method
to all this large expansion,
and in order to
get to that I think
I should talk about a quote that
our founder, Sir Fazle Hasan
Abed, talks about a lot of time,
which is "Poverty is not just
poverty of money or income.
We also see a poverty of
self-esteem, hope, opportunity,
and freedom.
People trapped in a
cycle of destitution
often don't realize their lives
can be changed for the better
through their own activities.
Once they understand that, it's
like a light gets turned on."
So at BRAC, we are
in the business
of turning those lights on.
So whether it's about financial
inclusion, or education, or any
of our livelihoods
program, it's all about
turning that light on,
giving people the tools
so that they can
change their lives.
So today I'm going to tell you
two stories, 30 years apart,
about two of the biggest
challenges we have faced
and what we learned about
the role of technology
and social innovation
in those challenges.
So first case story is about
fairly low tech solution
with a high touch approach.
Imagine you are an
illiterate mother
back in the early
80s in Bangladesh,
in rural Bangladesh.
You live in an
extremely remote region,
the country is still
reeling economically
from the war that happened
about 10 years ago.
But this isn't your
biggest concern.
Your concern is about
your sick child, who
was suffering from diarrhea.
And your thoughts are
consumed with her,
because you don't
know what to do.
The nearest hospital
is about five miles,
you don't have the money to
take your child to the hospital.
You don't have access
to any physician nearby.
So what do you do
in that situation?
Particularly when you
know that about one
out of five children
in your community
dies suffering from diarrhea.
Dehydration that's caused
from diarrhea and cholera
was one of the primary
killers of child
under five in Bangladesh.
About one out of seven children
in Bangladesh right after war
would actually won't make
it to their fifth birthday.
So when that's the
scenario you're working on,
actually this kind of related
of why we had so many children,
each household had so
many children in there,
because if you don't know
how many would survive,
you actually don't think about
family planning that much.
Actually recently,
there was a quote
by Melinda Gates
the other day, who
highlighted that "if parents
believe their children
will survive and if they
have the power to time
and space their
pregnancies, that they would
choose to have fewer children."
So parents living in
poverty in rural Bangladesh
didn't have control of what
their children's lives are
or their futures.
So it wasn't that there wasn't
a solution available, there was.
Actually in the 60s, there was
a breakthrough in treatment
for diarrhea, right?
A concoction of
water, sugar and salt
called oral rehydration
therapy, or ORT was tested
by a group of researchers.
However this
concoction, if given
to the children
at the right time,
would actually save 96.5%
of the children, as opposed
to 70% who would not make it.
But there was another problem.
The treatment was out of
reach for poor families
and remained mostly
in the hospitals.
Because one, you had to
get the proportion right.
The researchers did have
the idea that at some point,
they will market
it and they will
make the instruction
available for people,
but when you have
illiterate mothers
all around the country,
the instructions
actually not very useful.
When you have instructions about
giving spoons and measurements
right, when most
of the households
don't have even spoons,
doesn't really work.
So what do you do in
that kind of situation?
Because if you don't get
the measurement right,
if you have too much salt,
it may kill your baby.
If you have too much
sugar, it may actually
reverse the effect
of the ORT saline.
So that's where, I guess, the
power of delivery comes in.
Around that time, BRAC
was about 10 years old.
And there was a guy
called Sir Fazle Hasan
Abed who moved back from London,
leaving his cushy job at Shell
Oil, and decided
that he was going
to actually work
towards rebuilding
the country after the war.
And pretty soon, the
relief organization
actually slowly expanded into
other development activities.
And he was from
the private sector,
and he understood
scale very well,
and he was all about
problem solving.
So when he heard about the
problem, one of the things
that he tried, he started
experimenting in his kitchen
with unrefined
sugar known as gur
in Bangladesh, which is fairly
well available in rural areas.
So he found out that
about three finger pinch
of salt, a handful
of sugar, gur,
and half a liter of boiled water
actually can make the same,
have the same effect that
this World Health Organization
that came up with the antidote
for, the ORT solution.
So that's how easy to
make solution arrived.
But then how do you
actually teach it
to the rest of the country?
How do you actually
go to mothers
and tell them that this
is actually going to work,
and this is what you should do?
So that's where the
biggest challenge came in.
And World Bank's president
recently said the quote
that "it's not the question
of what to deliver,
it's about it's about
how to deliver it."
In the social
development space, it's
all about not innovation
itself, but how do you actually
deliver the innovation.
So a media advocacy
campaign wouldn't
have worked at that time
because only 20% of people
have access to radio
and television.
So it would have to be
sandals on the ground.
People talking to people,
people changing behaviors.
So that's what
BRAC started to do.
So it recruited
small groups of women
from communities to become
health promoters themselves.
The groups traveled on
foot, went door to door,
showing mothers how to
make these solutions.
Later monitors went in and
checked how many of those
mothers actually learn how
to make those solutions.
And it was an iterative process,
there were failures plentiful.
We learned as we went along.
So staff tweaked their
approach as they went along.
And one thing, sorry, one
example of our learning
has been that when
the monitors went back
after the first lot
of training happened,
we found out that about
90% of these mothers
learned how to make
those solutions.
So you would think
that was a success.
But only 10% of them actually
gave it to their children
when their children were sick.
So people were scratching
their heads, what went wrong?
A group of anthropologists
were sent to do some research,
and they found out
was very interesting,
not rocket science.
But because the fathers weren't
involved in this process
and they were the
key decision makers,
so they actually
wouldn't let the mothers
give this strange concoction to
their child when they got sick.
So that's when the
next battle started.
So we started training men.
We started treating the fathers.
And this is just
an example, but as
other issues evolved, the
process was continuously
modified, which led to
continuous improvement
of the outcome itself.
So BRAC then worked with
the Bangladeshi government,
of course, to kind of
scale up nationwide.
It basically, eventually,
went to every single household
in Bangladesh, teaching
mothers how to make ORT.
And that's a media
advocacy campaign
followed to sustain
the effect, eventually.
And just to kind of
finish off the story,
there was this long article
on this in New Yorker magazine
a couple of years ago.
I'm just going to
read a few quotes.
"Coaxing villagers to make this
solution with their own hands
and explain the messages
in their own words
while a trainer
observed and guided
them achieved far more
than any public service
ad or instructional
video could have done.
Over time, the changes could
be sustained with television
and radio and the
growth of demand
led to the development
of a robust market
for manufactured oral
rehydration salt.
Three decades later
national surveys
have found that almost 90% of
children with severe diarrhea
were given the solution.
Child deaths from diarrhea
plummeted more than 80%
between 1980 and 2005.
Bangladesh now has the highest
use of ORT in the world."
So this is the
quote I love, and I
think it's relevant to a lot
of you who are in technology.
I mean, "we yearn
for frictionless,
technology solutions.
But people talking to
people is still the way
norms and standards change."
So there were some
early lessons in this,
just to quickly summarize.
Even 30 years ago.
I know data is big now,
but even 30 years ago, data
was king then at
that time as well.
We constantly looked at
the numbers and evolved.
Number two, social
innovation is not just
about product innovation.
It's about a continuous process
of adjustment and tweaking
as you go along.
It's about process
innovation as well.
And number three, the
simpler your solution is,
the easier it is to scale.
So it's very, very
relevant to the part
of the world we operate in.
So fast forward
about 30 years later.
So this is the second story
I'm going to talk about,
which is more about when
high tech meets high touch.
How do you get rural women,
and men of course, to trust
and understand that mobile
money will improve their lives?
Just to set a context,
there's a story
that our microfinance
director talks about,
that when we
introduced mobile money
for our microfinance borrowers
to pay their loans on time,
they would send the mobile
money through their phone
and then they would
walk to our offices
and come and make sure that
it actually has come through.
Because in a country
where system often fails,
you always want
that piece of paper,
to make sure that this is
your proof that you actually
have done it, you
don't actually have
a lot of trust in your system.
So it was actually
quite interesting,
because to have them trust an
SMS message of confirmation
was actually quite
a large shift.
So the idea for
mobile money came in
from a different context.
I mean, I think when, 30
years later, Bangladesh
has become a lot more urbanized,
it's not as rural anymore.
Also people have become
a lot more mobile.
They're traveling,
they're seasonal migrants
who are coming back and forth
from villages to cities,
they're working in
the cities and they
want to send money
to their families.
So there was a big need of safe,
reliable and affordable means
of sending money back home.
Of course, people found very
creative way of sending money.
They send it through the
overnight bus service,
they would send the money
through post-office,
through selling airtime,
or physically carrying cash
home every few months.
But there was a big need or
something which actually did it
quickly and reliably.
So that's where the solution
came in, which is the Bkash,
the mobile financial service.
It inspired by the
success in East Africa,
with M-Pesa and some
of the other companies
that worked really
well in Africa.
BRAC bank started Bkash
in 2011, with a mission
towards including
the very bottom
of the people, financially.
Which means that actually,
not only just remittance
but the big vision is that
introducing financial products
and services that
works for the poor.
So it was a great
fit for Bangladesh,
because in Bangladesh
we have 90%
of the household has
mobile phone, but only 30%
has bank accounts.
So if you can give
people with the phone,
a bank account
should work wonders.
But the problem was, just to--
so before I get into
the problem a bit,
just to give you an
understanding of how
the solution worked, it's not
just a mobile to mobile money.
There's a role of
an agent network
within the organization.
The idea is that a
rickshaw puller, say,
who works in the city wants
to send money to his family,
would actually go to an
agent, who would actually
take the physical cash,
put it in his bank account,
mobile money account, and then
they have the money transferred
either directly to the
family or to an agent
who's lives nearby to
the other family member
and then the family
could use it.
I mean if the money
was transferred
to the bank account
of the sender,
they could also use it for
other purposes as well,
like buying things directly.
But we don't have
ecosystem yet quite ready,
so money's mostly being used
for remittance purposes.
So this is how it worked.
But the problem was that it
also went on to the delivery.
Nobody knew Bkash, right, why
would people's trust Bkash?
But everybody knew
BRAC at that time.
And BRAC's, this is
just our operations
in terms of where we are, in
terms of in the country itself.
So we have a network
all across the country.
So what we started to build
up was this agent network.
And we worked with all
these borrowers that we have
who actually own stores.
So there are these small
shop owners who we went to
and say that, you
know the community,
the community knows you, are
you interested to be an agent?
And initially, there was
not a lot of understanding,
but people came along listening
to us, because we said,
this is going to
work for you and this
is going to work for everybody
else in the community as well.
So 10,000 agents
signed up initially.
And once we did it, and that's
where the early adopters came
in, and then we started
working with growing
the user base going forward.
And the rest is
pretty much history,
because Bkash has seen
very, very rapid expansion
over the last five years.
Just to show you
some numbers, this
is a slightly dated
number, but we now have,
it is now the largest
mobile financial service
in terms of how many
people have direct accounts
in the world right now.
We have about, in Bangladesh,
we have about 41 million people
with accounts, and about 80% of
them are Bkash account holders.
You can see some of the
numbers, the rapid growth.
We have almost close
to about $50 million
being transacted daily.
Now the agent network
boasts about 600,000
around the country.
It all just happened
in just four years.
But we didn't want to
rest in this laurel,
however, because as I said,
that the primary mission was
to actually empower
the poor financially.
So we looked at
the numbers again,
and we saw that there were
far less women who signed up
than men for Bkash accounts.
And at the same time, people
were still accessing it
primarily as through the agent
network not directly accessing
themselves.
And if you don't access
it directly yourself,
then financial products and
services built up for you,
you're not going to actually
see a lot of benefit for it.
So I'm going to
see a small video
in terms of how we took
that as a next step,
in terms of increasing
the literacy for women.
And this will probably
give you a bit
of a glimpse of what we mean
by this high touch involvement.
Let's look at a two
minute video very quickly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ASIF SALEH: So the
work is still ongoing.
I think the user experience
needs to be a lot better,
so we're working on that.
But I think there are
some key learnings, right,
in both these two stories.
So I think person to
person interaction
does shift social
norms and builds trust.
And for a lot of
technology adoption,
it's not just about
technology itself.
It's about changing mindsets.
So it's very important
to have that person
to person interaction.
And then secondly, which is
very relevant to the first one,
that it's not just not
the product itself,
and it's not how we
deliver technology,
it's actually as
important, if not more
than the technology itself.
And the last one is that when
high tech meets high touch,
the early days of
tech adoption actually
really happens at that time.
And I think that's also
where the magic happens.
And I want to sort
of end on that note
that, sitting in 2017
right now, there are so
many immense sort of progress
that has happened in technology
and about to come in
the next few years.
We are looking at some
amazing disruption
can happen in this market.
You can think about, imagine
if these 100,000 health
promoters who are
across the country
having access to this diagnostic
tool who can go house to house,
collect data, send
data to the cloud,
have AI engine looking at it,
give some diagnostic ideas,
and link them to specialists
all around the world.
Amazing things can happen.
I'm thinking very
focused, customized,
specific, financial
products being delivered
to various groups all
around the country,
because you have
access to the data.
Bkash is sitting on a
huge data gold mine,
understanding when people
send money, what people will
do with the money,
you can actually
come up with very, very useful
products in the coming days.
You can look at the
jobs market in form
of both, how you can make
matches so that you can
increase the wages for the
people who don't have access
to those key information.
So amazing things can
happen in the coming days.
I just want to sort of
think that if Google,
with all its resources, smarter
engineers, that you guys are
all out here, you can
partner with some of the more
sophisticated distribution
network that we have at BRAC,
real magic can happen
in the coming days
and real disruption can happen.
And personally speaking
over the last few years.
As I have learned to
have bigger dreams,
I actually have learned to
appreciate slow innovation
a lot more than I used to.
This is a picture
of a train station,
particularly during
a festival time.
I love to show this picture
in our presentation.
I mean, it's
chaotic region, it's
a chaotic country, enormously
resource constrained.
But at the same time,
enormous social capital,
enormous resilience that is
built into the social fabric
of the country.
So we do come up with this
interesting social innovation.
So I actually have a lot
more appreciation for this
than I used to have in the past.
So I will conclude at
that and then would
love to hear you
guys in the coming--
thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: So the
first question is,
how can Global Tech companies
based in Silicon Valley
work with BRAC
across these existing
programs in micro-finance,
healthcare, education, et
cetera?
Is it possible to collaborate
on opportunities, ideas?
ASIF SALEH: Yeah
I think there are
more opportunities than
ever now, because not only--
so BRAC actually
works in Bangladesh
and 11 other countries in
Asia and Africa as well.
We almost use Bangladesh as
a hub for experimentation.
So the idea is that we
have these large sort
of distribution channels
as I was mentioning,
both in the financial sector,
education, and other sector,
which lets us scale
up relatively easily.
But what we lack is
we don't have so much
technical prowess over there.
And I think with the
infrastructure getting
ready in the country
and also the region,
it's not so much about all
the access is an issue,
I think there's still
an issue but they're
are going to be resolved
very quickly in the next two
or three years.
But what we lack is this
matchmaking to happen.
I think basically we need
smarter products and services
that are designed, built for,
thinking about those people
in the next billion market.
And then we need a very
smart distribution channel
and this high touch
approach that we mentioned.
So we have a social
innovation lab
at BRAC, which looks at
some of these issues.
This innovation fund, thing
that you saw-- innovation
mobile money thing that
you saw on the video,
it's being supported
by Gates Foundation,
but this is something that
is run by the Innovation Lab
So we are looking constantly
at external opportunities
where we can make these matches.
So I think particularly
in the next three
or four years, I see a lot of
these kinds of partnerships
being built. Because in
every sector, whether you
call it health, education,
financial sector, agriculture,
technologies is
becoming the disruptor.
And the foster we adopt
and have those high touch
approaches, I think there
are tremendous gains
to be made in the coming days.
SPEAKER 1: So is BRAC doing
any programs for startups
in developing countries?
ASIF SALEH: Yes.
What we have started
in Bangladesh,
we have had a number of things
both internally and externally,
from the lab, we run a number of
innovation funds, very focused.
So one thing we started,
Mobile Money Innovation Fund,
where we asked our
large workforce,
there was internal
competition, we
said, give us your idea
on how mobile money can
improve service delivery
for the poor people.
That attracted a
lot of intrapreneurs
to give their ideas,
and some of these ideas
were piloted and expanded.
Then we launched
another innovation fund
for urban challenges.
Urbanization, as you know, is
the biggest challenge, and now
unplanned urbanization
in that part.
So we asked for external
companies and innovators
to give their ideas.
So what we are doing now
is we are incubating them
for about a year.
So we are working
with them in terms
of grounding their
ideas with our network,
and then if some of
these actually stick,
then we are going
to help them launch
to become a full fledged
company and help them
with initial financing.
We are also expanding and
doing a lot of investments
in terms of some of
the new startups.
We just recently made an equity
investment in a tech startup
called Maya, who's founder
is here, Ivy Russell.
Maya is doing
great work in terms
of creating a
community for women
and providing them
basic services.
So they have some
fantastic ideas
on expansion going
forward as well.
So the idea is not that BRAC
will have to do everything.
The idea is that as long as
it is true to the mission,
we will have a network
of organizations
who will do the same
work that we want to do.
And sometimes actually,
they can do it better.
They're very focused
and they actually
can do the work a lot better.
So in the coming days, you'll
see a lot more expansion
like this where we are going
to be investing in companies.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that BRAC
has moved into other countries.
So I'm curious what
changes and what
stays the same when you take
programs to other countries?
ASIF SALEH: Very good question.
Actually a lot changes.
We don't necessarily
take everything as is.
And sometimes also, not
necessarily everything
happens in Bangladesh
first, sometimes
we also see the reverse
innovation as well.
But I think what
we see in common
is that across the new
countries we operate,
these are mostly fragile
economies, or either
post conflict countries.
So we start, typically,
with micro microfinance,
financial inclusion.
And then as it starts
to build the network,
then we go into other programs.
In some areas that we
see that a common element
is the role of the community,
the social capital.
We have certain things very
common across the board.
We tried to build them as
part of the program design.
We have the notion of
the social network,
we formed these clubs
with young people
in Uganda which
works really well
which, again, the genesis came
from a program in Bangladesh,
but then it morphed
into something else.
In Bangladesh we didn't have
financial microfinance built
into the young people's clubs.
Here in Uganda, when we saw that
this was actually a big need,
because a lot of these--
early pregnancy
was a big problem,
and a lot of these
single mother they
want to get into jobs and
livelihood generations.
So we introduced the idea
of financial inclusion
fairly early in these clubs.
So that's how we actually
tweak the model over time.
And we are now looking at taking
some of our skills learning,
we have gone into the skills
program quite big in Bangladesh
and we want to take some of
those in other parts of Africa
as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the wonderful talk.
You talked about, when
you talked about Bkash,
you mentioned
about trust factor.
One of the area your
Bkash could be very useful
of the remittance
is the e-commerce.
And e-commerce has a huge amount
of trust factor deficiency.
What do you learn in
the remittance sections
of the Bkash transaction
that could be useful
for e-commerce as well in
Bangladesh or outside as well?
ASIF SALEH: So I think
e-commerce in Bangladesh
is starting to take off, but
there are still lots of issues,
because the ecosystem
is not quite built yet.
You still have problems with
the delivery of packages
and so the distribution
channel is not quite there.
But I think we are
seeing, if you look at,
although the numbers are fairly
small in the early stage,
if you look at the numbers,
they look very, very promising.
But interestingly, we
have a large retail chain
called Aarong, those of you
from Bangladesh know Aarong.
It actually started aarong.com
about three years ago.
And from some of
the numbers there,
we see not different
from India, people still
are not very comfortable in
doing electronic purchasing.
They are still doing
cash on delivery.
The cash on delivery is not
good for e-commerce sector,
but people are still more
comfortable in doing that.
And so in aarong.com's number,
about 70% of the purchases
still happen through COD's.
And Bkash numbers are
relatively smaller,
but I think that's also due to
the fact of user experience.
I think Bkash is
launching a new app
in this year, which is
going to make the user
experience a lot better.
But once that happens,
the Bkash should take off
more quickly than credit card,
because credit card is more
difficult. I think nobody
is hand-holding anybody
in e-commerce, I think
that's the big factor.
But this notion of
associated e-commerce
has started in India, which
basically uses intermediary,
right?
So you have these centers
where people can go to
and they have access to internet
and laptops and all that,
and they help you browse.
This is what you have available,
and then they let you buy it,
and the packages actually
come to that center.
And so they take a small cut
and then they make the fee.
So that's becoming also, that
has also started to happen.
So I think same kind
of hand-holding,
so somebody to take them through
that experience initially,
that needs to happen.
So I think that that's
interesting learning,
because right now
we are just kind
of assuming that its just
going to happen automatically,
and it's not.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Last
question, I guess
it's coming from
the Dory, is BRAC
considering expanding to India?
ASIF SALEH: This request
has come in quite a lot,
but in the past we have
worked with partners in India.
India is a bit more complicated
in terms of regulations.
So what we want to do
is work with partners.
I think we have got
specific invitations
to work in the education
sector, microfinance sector.
So we worked with a
company called Bandhan
in the past, which was
started by a former BRAC staff
and now has become the largest
microfinance Institute in India
and has become the
big national bank.
So yeah, we would love to work
in India as long as we can find
the right partner,
but we are not
going to directly start
an operation there.
Thank you so much
for your time, and--
[APPLAUSE]